let's talk to Mary Jean because we need
to get to the bottom of a lot of what
happened with this election last night
and a lot of the networks had exit
polling we had our own person on the
street doing a exit polling and that's
Mary Jean
any luck with that yeah that's Mary Jean
or you she was out on the streets of New
York City getting to the bottom of who
people were voting for and why which i
think is very very valuable don't you I
don't disagree yeah now we have to
respect people's privacy a lot of people
might have said that they didn't want to
tell us who they were voting for sure
because it's a secret it's a secret -
secret ballot but Mary Jean does tend to
get to the bottom of things she's just a
good investigative reporter good you
need that she's also uh uh stripper
titty shaker she's been in porn movies
she certainly has been she recently had
anal for the first time oh good only a
couple of months ago so she's got a lot
of qualifications there she is
Mary Jean the program how are we I'm
good
see I felt like we had coverage of the
election for the first segment of the
show but it wasn't woke enough you know
what I mean
and Mary I feel like you are woke yes
I'm awake that's exactly right that's
what I was referring to
so did you did you did you vote
yesterday um to be honest am tell me I
forgot to register so I didn't but I
will like in four years I think you
could just register day of yeah a lot of
people dead so why did register day of
um I didn't because I was out reporting
for you guys and you know how many were
you reporting for us not long you know
yeah so what were you doing for the rest
of the day uh masturbating okay agents
yeah I came a few times so it's all good
before after your reporting duties both
okay that's good yeah and watch some
porn lesbian porn you did a little fight
do you like when they use toys and
lesbian porn now what is her
neither what do you like licking right
sucking right [ __ ] annoying
backing yeah you are not and pulled some
people yeah thanks so much fun
were you surprised at the results that
you got I got a lot of haters you did
yeah why would you get haters yeah like
people are like you're acting on your
propria questions well what about you do
you think your questions were
unappropriate on appropriate that's he
just said oh like no the other were them
inappropriate yeah oh my god okay do you
think they were do you think they were
inappropriate no there were normal
things normal things that people do on a
regular basis on an election day right
yeah especially on uh on a Tuesday
Monday filled with tension and
uncertainty yes yes you need to come on
days like that you do well here's a Mary
Jean she was talking to Britt by the way
Mary Jean a lot of people don't know is
not only a stripper not only an actress
of adult of films but also a hairstylist
she's got all the things of town yeah
I didn't hear so long Joe Weiss yeah
[ __ ] with Tony Montana's sister uh
here's Mary Jean talking to Britt come
back it's Mary Jean again and what's
your name sir Simon Simon Simon are you
from England you said I am from England
yet you get to vote in England oh yeah
yeah we do yeah we always have to have
the same Queen you never yeah we don't
find Queen both the oops oh it's a Brit
Oh Oh a Brit Adrian just being [ __ ]
cute with his descriptions British man
but you didn't write a Brit Simon then
how come you hacking me incorrectly Mary
Jean we're a communion be like I didn't
talk to anybody named Brit I thought I'd
dad there's so many people thing I get
you I get you I'm back it's Mary Jean
again and what's your name sir Simon
Simon Simon are you from England you
said I am from England yet do you get to
vote in England oh yeah yeah
yeah she always have the same queen you
never yeah we don't vote for the Queen
oh well we have presidents here you know
yeah you don't have a you know we'd have
a royal family which is a bit like a
tourist attraction
the Prime Minister is supposed to be in
charge
yeah well supposedly Hillary's gonna
take it charge full charge yeah yeah do
you think she eats [ __ ] oops
probably no no I think she does like
maybe on the weekends when she likes
free champagne gets Lou okay so just get
in the bottom of some things there were
rumors that she might uh enjoy the
company of other women that's what I
heard word on the street Yeah right
right you might be right were you super
did you hear who won the election uh
yeah yeah when did you hear um like this
morning on Twitter you did you didn't
hurt last night I fell asleep
no I smashed the rating and I came and
then I was like oh I got it I get that
so how did you feel when you found out
Hillary did not win Donald it I feel
like he's gonna be a good president
might as well like we can't go back you
know why do you think Donald's gonna be
a good president
cuz he's like a great actor oh I see how
like if he could do that maybe he could
run the country you know he's a great
act Ronald Reagan was a great act or an
average act and he became president but
he had a little more experience then
Trump right right but but Trump has a
lot of acting experience
yeah and he's great in real estate and
every other stuff he does so he might
take over you never know what and when
he taking like taking down Obamacare -
it's right there
yeah I [ __ ] hate Obamacare why do you
hate Obamacare oh my god they fined me
last year
what Oh cuz I didn't get it yeah so it's
like what the [ __ ] I watched a the final
floor yeah it was like over a thousand
dollars it's insane like I could have
bought pair of shoes bought my dog
something right you know do you health
insurance and I do now after that
experience got it so now it's like [ __ ]
Abama care even though like Obama's okay
how much they're costing the year um the
Friars know for insurance insurance I
was paying like 500 every month insane
oh it's a lot that's a lot of money
that's a lot of money what about the
fight you I mean this is like I miss
bush because of that I bet you miss bush
hey what do you think what do you think
of how the fact that we're gonna have
inarguably
the hottest first lady that we've ever
had everybody's gonna come every [ __ ]
day you think so you think people get
come to Melania Trump um yeah who
haven't already to those like racy
pictures that sure Jackie I'll look like
a pig have you ever masturbated to a
first lady before Mary Jean to Jackie
all yeah good for you yeah she look so
cool with that pillbox hat in her hand
said all right you moved on you went
very international with this with with
this crowd that you found you talked to
an Australian girl yeah about uh I guess
Donald Trump in the whole election right
yeah okay let's hear hey what's your
name cardi oh that's so cute I love that
name makes me want to get any good what
was the name kirti kirti yeah and you
just hear that name you know what it's
weird jim has a new nickname on the show
what is it
chip Kirti that's kirti kirti kirti yeah
how do you feel right now oh my god
horny like didn't have a bra like I know
my nipples are hard behind my bra they
are yeah I'm actually wearing one
tonight why cuz I'm a cream color sure
and like that's why you shouldn't wear
one yeah exactly
breast eagle what kind of bra are you
wearing a black one Yeah right prove it
oh wow it is my boy those are big ones
she have big nipples she certainly does
her large areolas he like them she's a
busty gal he's a busty gallon maryjean
doesn't right doesn't she yeah she's a
chesty young lady yes yes we love it
very buxom very buxom do you rub your
boobs when you masturbate um not really
not so much not unless I can't come then
I squeeze my nipples like [ __ ] comp it
helps me to my nipples they're really
dead that the X Factor right Jim likes
to just kind of tenderly like kind of
brush his hands against his nipples yeah
I just make sure everything ok so get
you harder and harder yeah it just makes
everything alright like things are wrong
that make you horny Mary Jean it is now
that's what I thought
hey what's your name tardy oh that's so
cute I bet that makes me want to get me
good yeah what's your name babe
Cassie Cassie that's cool where you guys
from from Australia oh my god they have
two kangaroos and like everything super
cute out there
kangaroos not so much but where's that
fob yeah they're not cute what if I can
[ __ ] oh my god who did he vote for the
Labour Party that sounds interesting it
sounds while is it like the Tea Party
different compulsory they teachers very
different things here in school we see
parties like equals strip club kind of
thing what while I thought that means
Nazi Party and [ __ ] alright you ever
try to run for a beauty pageant just so
you can you know know all right I
wouldn't either though yeah me too I
love lesbian oh yeah why not thank you
my only criticism and it's a very minor
one is try to make them if you can so we
can hear them but it's very entertaining
right right yeah I don't know is explain
to me your theory about the Tea Party
thing a straight America being the strip
club because I thought that the Tea
Party was like the predecessor to the
alright more conservative they were yeah
they were a more conservative branch of
the Republicans that's what you think I
thought so but it maybe I'm wrong yeah I
bet you behind closed doors they're
really party afterwards like what did
people do before like 9/11 they used to
use their corporate cards to go to strip
club they used to work all day and then
go to strip clubs so this is what's
happening in the Tea Party why did 9/11
stop there everything shut down I don't
know they told me it's yeah cuz it's
been like 15 years yeah well that's why
a lot of people don't go to the strip
clubs anything because of 9/11 yeah
because they don't want to use their
regular money like their pocket money
and they can't use their their like
corporate money so you're saying that
the corporate money ran out yeah after
9/11 there was no more stripper money
that's what everybody complains and
every guys that goes to a strip club
know
that they always go oh they always say
oh before 9/11 I wish you were dancing
right they keep saying that party
they're cheap yeah suzy is it excuse
they're allowed to use their corporate
cards they're just lying party wait you
think they've been lying to me this
whole time yes I do because they're
being cheapskates they want to blame
them because no one can combat 9/11
they say 9/11 people just all okay oh
yeah that's for sure that's their
scapegoat [ __ ] I've been tricked
that's it that's what's happening like
you like whispering in their ear do you
want a third song and no you [ __ ] I
do but 9/11 yeah exactly the terrorists
win gotta go home and [ __ ] my fat wife
and then what do you say yeah 9/11 oh
yeah 9/11 I can't argue that I guess but
how is the Tea Party a strip club
fun times oh I see that makes sense that
makes sense yeah I hadn't heard that
waited before that makes perfect sense
yeah I knew the Tea Party remind me of
something I didn't realize it was that
red strip clubs and fun times yes you're
right that's cool that's cool
won't you talk to uh I don't know who
this was this is somebody else though
hey what's your name Richard Richard you
look like corker bean really come on do
you why I didn't quite hear that yeah
yeah let's let's you know I am free hey
what's your name Richard Richard you
look like corker beans
Carla bean quarterback or curb and
corporate babe so you met somebody on
the street that look like corker bait
for Cobain I liked em yeah yeah corker
bait that I love this band novella
that's really good corker bein corker
bein it's like a Batman villain to just
a closed bottles of wine all the time
work urbane I get it yeah yeah it was
corker baina
was he handsome guy yeah he was
Caucasian do you like Caucasians
yeah it's specially on Tuesdays y on
Tuesdays that's what I was doing
yesterday talking to a lot of white
people oh why do I know people of color
I got I got one african-american did
they just not stop for you like you're
like oh could I talk to you and they're
like they gave me the look like leave me
alone [ __ ] what look Oh II mean yeah
maybe you should have stopped them maybe
they would have talked
my boobs that would work that would work
yeah next time that would work like
Jim's been glaring at you the whole show
have you been noticing Clara is a mean
thing I don't know known James but I
don't know how you're gonna stop him
from giving you dirty looks though you
know there's a guy how to hold on a
second say the name Jim Norton don't buy
yeah [ __ ] on my artistic hole literal
just trying to get using I know I know
no no Mary could you show Jim your
breasts oh you have to I'm trying to be
more artful about it yeah oh yeah I I
guess that would change your attitude
right boobs like let's just say I was
annoyed at you like what do you want I
don't want to answer any questions
oh yeah why don't know might be uh Oh
Sheldon my [ __ ] roleplay little that
would do it right right I think so too
especially if you decided to show them
your [ __ ] you know underpants on now I
forgot to put them on I guess I don't
believe you mmm she forgot to put the
monkey she did she said you forgot to
put on Underpants this morning yeah it
is you know rush I understand what were
you doing before you left the house
coming oh really this morning mm-hmm
you had breakfast and masturbated oh no
I came first and then I have breakfast
on the way Oh what you eat on the way
hash browns
and strawberry colada oh that sounds
delicious let's hear what's your core
core babe hey what's your name Richard
oh wait wrong button I think no is it oh
is he
so his name's Richard Bri looks like
corker Bay yeah okay hey what's your
name Richard Richard you look like
corker bane really yeah you still look
like a rocker guy thank you
oh did you vote for Hillary no I voted
for Gary Johnson well Gary you were
unfamiliar with Gary Johnson who's Gary
right right you didn't know at the time
yeah libertarian well he's a libertarian
candidate which party do you line
yourself up with is it one of the third
are all the parties she's got a hand up
a makeover cool but like like of the
third parties is there one like like the
Jill Stein
who's Joe oh okay it is the Green Party
victory Oh green is nice I like that
color
those guys agree so maybe you would like
that party maybe it's possible right
yeah if they have champagne I'm down you
didn't get a chance to vote yesterday
though I didn't get to register right
who would you have voted for Hillary
because she got boobs okay that's smart
actually that's what's very smart yeah
hey what's your name Richard Richard you
look like corker beans oh my god you
still look like a rocker guy thank you
oh did you vote for Hillary no I voted
for Garry Johnson who's Gary
Oh like uh independent contractor kind
of yeah pretty much
okay I wonder if he filled out a 1099 no
idea um oh my oh who cares right I
didn't vote for Hillary everybody vote
for Hillary I just had like either oh
come on she's like a lesbian you know
she's horrible but she's okay she has a
great fashion son I wouldn't go that far
the pantsuit on hold on she's a terrible
dresser man I think she's a great
dresser oh she's awful she's been
dressing like [ __ ] night a lot she
dresses like my grandmother's living
room she awful wood outfits do you like
the Hillary worse I like the white one I
like the red one the full red one that's
a good outfit yeah look at that jacket
or jacket flowers with all the [ __ ]
flowers and autumn leaves on yeah she
you know she sticks to one color when
she dug she kind of looks like the Tully
Toby crew right there and other than
that she she likes she rocks you don't
think it's a little too monochromatic no
she tries to pool I like it you do yeah
nice and tight
look at her skirts her pencil skirts
yeah I don't think she's a good
restaurant we have to disagree on yeah
it's okay I see worse she's like a monk
or something
looks like religious garb I like it you
think it do you think it's good yeah I
dig it she was a great fashion sense you
also think she's a lesbian though
correct honestly I swear she yeah I
don't even think she's bisexual huh
all right well let's see what a corker
Bane things there goes Lisa yeah
depended contract there kind of yeah
pretty much
okay
I wonder if he filled out a 1099 no idea
um who my oh who cares are you why
didn't you vote for Hillary everybody
vote for Hillary loaded come on she's
like a lesbian
you know she's horrible but she's okay
she has a great fashion son I wouldn't
go that far the pants suits are a little
much
yeah you definitely could see her ass
though I don't know if I want to look at
her ass now what do you think about
Melania pretty attractive yeah you think
she likes a no I wouldn't know maybe
Donald would answer that one right he
definitely looks like he likes a no to
this or to mr. Tim finger I like the
fist better too right yeah you think
well honey it looks like she probably
likes anal yeah she's like European
that's all I can tell they love Eva did
you like it when you did it um I was
more excited I wish I would have smoked
some weed before I did it I did I would
have been more loose did it make you
feel you had to poo No thank God oh my
god that was my biggest fear that's why
I never tried it before you're afraid
you're gonna cause a problem
oh so embarrassing how did you prepare
um I didn't eat for like two days and on
I douche
oh yeah so it could be super clean sure
and that's it cool you told me when you
first did it you were very excited about
it I was I was like I was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] my [ __ ]
and then I was like [ __ ] more and
then he was trying to be gentle and then
I didn't know what was going on it was a
little confused yeah well you confused
about um I thought I was just gonna come
right away when they shoved a dick up my
ass and what happened I didn't come
right away
right more like a Oh put it in take it
out put it in like a tease and I was
like just put it in right weird you
don't need a tease no you like to come
yeah but I got I get what he was doing
he didn't want to tear up my inside he's
trying to be gentle that's very nice of
him a big penis or an average penis he
had a big penis yeah you gotta be
careful yeah yeah especially with the
[ __ ] yeah a lot of tender skin back
there am i right yeah I felt nice though
it did yeah you don't want him to do
damage hurt your roids Oh
do you have hemorrhoids maryjean yeah
I'll take that as a yes right cluster
yeah my [ __ ] is nice and like smooth
it is yeah it's very smooth smooth
smooth cold doesn't look like a cave
wall with a bushel of great no it's not
like either umm what made you think that
Gary Johnson was similar to an
independent contractor because like he's
running for his own party right
independent contractor I see now do you
consider because Donald Trump was
running for the Republican Party is he
also an independent contractor no he
runs for the Republicans okay but Gary
Johnson is running for the Libertarian
Party so it's like liberal like your own
stuff oh that's more like an independent
country yeah that makes sense to me that
makes sense let's go to Dave in Iowa
Dave welcome to Jim Norton Sam Roberts
Mary Jean is here with some of her
information she collected via the exit
polls okay but I want to say that it's
not coolest mrs. Hillary dresses like
dr. evil what do you think about that
Mary Geno's Hillary dresses like dr.
evil - poor dresser I can't even think
about what dr. evil looks like like
Hillary Clinton
she'll picture let's see dr. evil yeah
all dr. Eve oh my gosh she does that's
the guy with the pinky that's right oh
my god
do you think dr. Evil's hot because you
said you liked Hillary Clinton's fashion
sense and she does look he only wears
gray oh I see because though my god they
do dress a lot they do dresser what a
coincidence
coinkidink right yeah let's hear more of
who you met while you were out on the
street what type of haters did you say
that you dealt with the lesbians like
the two girls talking about the kangaroo
is that uh-oh you didn't like that they
said kangaroos weren't cute because
they're nasty animals yeah I think
they're cute me too I'd pet one you
would Pat one yeah what else would he
Pat um whatever also I was allowed to
pet without being fired every sexual in
here didn't it yeah attention since
Nicky cut with an
yeah would you pad a kangaroo yeah for
eclis speaking um yeah it was wrong yeah
I said they probably they smell bad too
mm-hmm I doubt it
well they're wild animals yeah they
stink you're still talking about dicks
yeah oh so was I my diction a wild
animal it smells bad and the lesbians
didn't treat you well from Australia
they gave me a lot of nasty face
expression why why do you think that is
because I started talking about animals
I guess Australians don't like that do
you think that maybe sometimes women are
like jealous of you mm-hmm
you don't think so no they got boobs
dude maybe they didn't like the the
sexual nature or the sensual nature of
your talk
provocative provocative good you think
so they might have been a little taken
aback by it are you telling me Jim they
don't like coming oh no I'm going to
never disagree I think they do like to
come but the right to talk about
publicly their prior embarrassed weird
they're ashamed I wonder if they use
their fingers that's it ask them yeah
shut up
you could ask I couldn't ask that
question it would seem harassing but if
a hot girl ass is a different it's a
different tone do you know Mary Jean has
fisted [ __ ] before have a good time
I love it where have you done that I'm
like out like my friends houses just you
bet you've small hands yeah that's why I
think they love my little phalanges what
do you put a glove on go ahead
she pees what are come on jeez Oh oh so
do you do you finger the ass first
um yeah be like [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I just like spit on the okay I learn
how to do it the right way because
before I didn't use a condom and then I
will have that after anal smell on my
hand yeah yeah can smell like someone's
[ __ ] yeah but it didn't smell like
dirty [ __ ] it just smell like a baby
donkey it's not weird like it's more
like a come smell okay but not like it
not like come though yeah not like how
it smells like when you come from your
ass yeah not like a regular [ __ ] calm
more like a like a stint
like a mold you smell will do yeah like
a baby donkey like a baby donkey yeah so
like I learned how to put a condom now
over my whole hand and I just
why not just get a deli glove why a
condom over your whole hand because who
carries a glove I feel that way about
condoms Jim's like who is a [ __ ]
condom lying around the fisting thing
Wow
have you ever been fisted oh yeah I have
a couple of fingers I can take and I'm
all good but a fist no absolutely if you
could take two fingers you could take FS
yeah that's what I said to myself but it
just doesn't work out no way do you
think you could fist Jim if he lets me I
don't want a sexual harassment nikkor
take a fist couple a couple of fingers
in there just to straight me out who's
the boss a big [ __ ] right I'm done
that's it yeah that's that my [ __ ]
just does not tolerate that behavior but
Mary gee what have we learned where
there's a will there's a way right yeah
that's right that's right
let's keep going with some of the people
that you talk to exit polling here in
Manhattan yesterday so hi it's Mary Jean
again what's your name mark mark kelly
mark le or my international people yeah
oh my god everybody was from Europe yeah
so these people weren't actually voting
um no they couldn't write I thought
everybody moves to Canada or something
who like all the New Yorkers well
because they weren't I didn't find not
one single America huh very weird very
weird so hi it's Mary Jean again what's
your name
mark mark any mark Lu are you from I'm
from the UK oh my god I love do UK cuz
it's only two letter
yeah yeah you know what the UK stands
for United Kingdom there you go look
it's you I discussed it - you did yeah
you were right is it good yes it's great
guess so hi it's Mary Jean again what's
your name
mark mark kelly mark Lu are you from I'm
from the UK oh my god do UK coz it's
only two letter yeah yeah yeah it's an
easy right just like us
yeah huh oh my god I get it I never got
her before says you didn't let's here in
America who would you vote what um I
would be probably voting against rather
than for who's that for [ __ ] with me
I've been voting against ratted or who's
that and you're like who's rather than
four oh that's what you meant
yeah oh you thought rather than four is
the same person no no no right Oh who's
that yeah no let's see so hi it's Mary
Jane again what's your name Mark Martin
Kelly where you from I'm from the UK oh
my god I love do UK cuz it's only
two-letter yeah yeah yeah it's an easy
right it's not us yeah huh oh my god I
get it I never got it before so you
wouldn't lived here in America who would
you vote what that's a difficult choice
I'm I would be probably voting against
rather than for who's that Donald Trump
against okay so you're such a Hillary
fan Ari I'm not such a Hillary fan but I
think she's preferable to Trump I love
there he goes
I've been holding against rather than
for so I vote against Donald Trump
and she goes also you're a giant Hillary
fan and he's like no that's the opposite
of what is I like I like better when
when you don't always you're not always
on the same pages these people you know
why because it leads to more exploratory
questions cuz you don't just let stuff
sit there you get to the bottom of stuff
that's why you're good reporter you ask
the questions that are on your mind did
you not know that US was an abbreviation
for our country no I forgot the a so
right what do you think US was United
States yeah yeah you're right but I mean
you said you forgot the annoyances the
United States of America that's all I
know
oh you but you've never heard somebody
again from the US mmm very rare that is
I sense a little more rare they go I'm
from the US only people from the Bronx
say I'm from the US what's like the
tempte fication of the US of A there's
always the a yeah have you heard about
the the recent hefty vacation of the US
of A have you ever tested huh tapped it
it's when you it's when you have a flu
and you sneeze and you [ __ ] into your
pantyhose Oh seriously yeah did you have
that's a test
oh I wouldn't know that's why we call
that the Tefft box in there yeah cuz if
you do everything and you would come in
with the flu you'd have to go in there
to do with that absolutely
Travis stays in there he spends most of
the shows testing into his pantyhose
yeah Travis it's true it's true oh you
think that's sexy
oh but he shits into his panty oh yeah
only here's the flow right can't help
himself it's a flu [ __ ] yes like onions
yeah Oh disgusting right gagging we have
one more clip here and it's a guy making
a point about democracy versus dynasty
what do you think about that in terms of
like do you feel like the election was
leaning towards a dynasty like a change
you want I think people wanted to change
um because we already got Obama so
everybody's like used to like you know
let's get something you know so every
every eight years they need something
new yeah before right
every four yeah but Obama did eight oh
yeah he did
isn't that crazy [ __ ] looks good too
he'd you're right and Clinton you're
right but what about the first Bush no
he only did four yeah odd that's right
Mary Jean you know your [ __ ] history
she wasn't political Esther yes she does
she's good
this is actually the same guy this is
the the British guy stuff did you like
bail uh at the time yeah do you just
call you should call Bill Clinton bill
yeah bail I know him he's a cool guy
same birthday so it's like hey Bill
you share the same birthday August 19
would you have sex with Bill Clinton oh
my god was stuck his [ __ ] deck and
then if he asked me to lick his [ __ ]
I think about it you just lick it on out
of front principle like I will put like
I will wipe the you know with baby wipe
first and then like I would think about
licking his I would you really wipe the
ass of the ex-president baby why just in
there you're gonna fight the bullet hold
on a second bill yeah please for the US
of A facing they're worried about the
problem later we're doing a lot later
would you let him put a cigar in your
vagina didn't he do that with Monica
that's what he did hmm I was lit it was
lit
you think that's sexy did you did that
with the intern that's a little
disrespectful to be honest really yeah I
love it you would know how about the
president mmm I don't know it's like I
gotta know a really good immigrant and I
want them to like get their passport so
I would do them a favor and we're going
for the to do something to get out of it
yeah yeah yeah what about a cigarette in
the [ __ ] just a cigarette
no no that's very offensive it is yeah
okay with a nice yeah I'm very anal
about certain things I guess that a pun
yeah you know what's your body being
used um I just don't like my body to be
disrespected I love having fun I love
coming I love swapping I love spitting I
love the cursing while coming and you
spit on people
um I'll spit like in your ass [ __ ] in
your deck yeah okay spitting you
spitting guys dicks before yeah all the
time
kill the whole open and just spit I go
huh yeah I I've gone like I'll spit like
you like that oh well she's cursing a
toy yeah you dick yeah do you like Bill
ah at the time yeah did you like that he
got heard from Monica will influence me
I think the medical Bernie laughs
something that a lot of politicians get
up to we do you think everybody's
getting head no I just think that yeah
I'm not I'm not a big fan of the
Clintons and what they what they've done
since with the Clinton Foundation and
all the scandals surrounding that don't
you feel they're like the Kennedys the
new hip Kennedys
great and you hip candidate definitely I
just okay as a non-us citizen I find it
incredible the out of a population of
over with 230 240 million people
everything like that Ellison a candidate
who's from the same family as a previous
president it's funny I've never met this
I've been saying that since day one yeah
it's uh that people glad other people
notice that [ __ ] yeah that's the best we
could do is is though is the [ __ ] the
same family again yeah good okay other
people see that and honestly like Obama
because he brought in Hillary as
Secretary of State that administration
was kind of coupled in with the Clinton
thing
so it was really it was it was Bush
Clinton Bush Clinton and now they're
trying to do another Clinton or before
Donald Trump showed up if Donald Trump
hadn't have showed up they were really
pushing for another Bush Clinton
yeah he's either gonna be Jeb Bush or
Hillary Clinton what you think a Jeb
Bush he was okay but I I don't remember
his face he didn't last long in the race
no he didn't he why he got bullied out
of it
Oh Donald Trump made him look like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] they became did they
just became entitled they can be their
turn again
yeah oh he looks like his father yeah
but he looks like a simp he does not he
doesn't he just like a little wimpy he
doesn't have a strong presence or face
yeah he's will eat his teeth then he'll
look stronger his teeth are not good
right now it's got a little bit of a
yellow hue to them no I don't like the
blue tie the yellow car no good yeah you
should stand up straight you don't think
he has a great body he could tone up
show the picture of the hoodie he has a
hoodie oh yeah Jimin hoodie really looks
kind of cool oh my God he's gangster you
think so you think that's gangster
apparently look couldn't look worse it
over huh why is he wearing a hoodie no
one ever wears a hoodie he looks like I
mean he looks like et oh he looks like
extraterrestrials if ur all the way up
and say yeah what a clod that is very
poor a chin definition yeah so I guess
there's kind of like a it just kind of
blends his chin blends into his neck I
understand the chin thing is my chin is
not as pronounced as people would
believe well it's gotten better and you
see much better used to be fairly bad
but you know you have to understand what
you can wear yeah is where things open
to highlight that there's more body
underneath the chin yes will you stop
your zipper in mid chest so that it
opens up before the chin you don't zip
it right up to the lack of chin right
that's why I like really really cold a
fair enough but it was really cold there
he's just doing that for a photo like
Mary if you're wearing a hoodie you're
probably only gonna zip it halfway up
the titties so you can still see some
cleave right or they just don't go up
because my boobs are so big they are
aren't they what size are they I really
don't know like 30 to something some 32
of those apps
I think so what are you wearing right
now you're wearing a bra
they're 32 Triple D triple D Triple D
yeah but I feel small like mint do you
want bigger breasts or no no I actually
want them smaller but I want to give
bear fur so then I can make them smaller
okay right
you're gonna give you want to give birth
and then shrink your parent breast down
yeah after cuz you know once you start
like producing milk they change right
it's soggy and all that are you on the
pill um yeah I'm trying to trick
somebody into getting pregnant has been
successful at all yet not yet but you
are working you are working on it though
yeah you got your period right now and
you're not wearing a panties I love her
she's [ __ ] yeah no I'm gonna plug I
don't have my period now no but like I
still get it you know okay
yeah I thought you had it now no string
is just like hey no great so if you're
with a guy you just tell him just do it
inside everything's fine
no like I'm planning to make holes in
the condoms so I can trick the guy but
like wait we use protection right right
right good for you because that's smart
because then you can not only get
pregnant but you can get him on the hook
for some child support right I didn't
think about the child support that's a
good idea to get some money yeah uh well
I was just hoping maybe he'll marry me
oh you think I like him enough that one
what do you know what if you don't like
him enough I'm gonna have to [ __ ]
like him I'm trying to trick him into
having a baby silly of me to ask yes
that's the plan is to like get yourself
on a husband not like a like sugar daddy
I see I see so you're gonna guilt him
into marrying you after you're pregnant
yeah so you're just gonna trick him the
whole way gotta do it it's right that's
right Mary you have you tried like
dating websites or anything like that no
no I'm not into that you don't like that
well you'd have to be cool with you
doing films and you dancing that's hard
for some guys yeah but that's in my past
life you should accept me for a pair
okay yeah sure yeah that would [ __ ] in
a while so so you wouldn't keep dancing
um yeah that's the plan I don't want to
be a stripper anymore after have a kid
Wow yeah and saw all these strippers now
that have kids and still dance yeah I
would be like a hypocrite well you got
your salon yeah salon how old
I am 27 okay so that's why now you're
thinking okay now is a good time to
start trying to trick somebody into
knocking me up and like in two years
yeah right right so beware [ __ ]
no yeah berry gene throws [ __ ] at you
before she's dirty are you worried about
divorce or anything like that um or that
doesn't really I'm hoping I don't get
divorced I don't think you will honest I
don't think you would like I'll be that
crazy [ __ ] you're not [ __ ] divorcing
me you know right right cuz you don't
want to get divorce cuz you don't want
to get violent yeah I get that
have you ever had a physical altercation
with a gentleman unfortunately yeah well
that's not my thing
drama drama happens well who started it
it's always done I'm always I'm like
Gandhi jam oh yeah yeah now what what
did he do that made that made him start
physic being physical not wanting to
have sex you do want to sell a lot of
guys do that yeah they think I just
automatically want to [ __ ] give them
a [ __ ] or I want to have sex with
them and it doesn't work like that
what did he do mmm I don't know they
could say like a rude comment and I
could say something back and they try to
shove me or something it happened like a
few times I shove you yeah yeah what was
your rude comment back you [ __ ] dick
or you know curse them out okay right
right
and then how did you end you hit them
back I try not to ever hit guys just
because I know I could get punched
sure sure can I just no no thank god no
I mean I wouldn't even know how to see
him I I would seek vengeance for you if
that had happened I actually did get
punched um but it wasn't like what was
it yeah well no when you got punched
yeah I call 9-1-1 well who punched you
or what was the relationship to the
person a [ __ ] Dyke who sexual
assaulted me so it was yeah Wow Amer at
work
no no outside like I went out okay yeah
what did he grab you yeah
did you bust him do you get him busted
what's the matter Mary Jean it's okay
let's talk about dicks and [ __ ] now
oh it's okay we didn't mean to to go
down any road you did a traumatic memory
orb you're sad because of the person
that happened with doesn't matter let's
keep talking about other stuff it's okay
I'm used to this reaction with women
looking at me right right right
sometimes they get emotional and yeah
just depressed and said my face has that
effect this is what I've got going for
me my face is known as a joy spoiler Oh
Mary we didn't mean to make you upset
you okay I'm fine okay not so well me
and I'm in very mean to bring up a bad
memory No so conversations go yeah guys
why is it something you haven't thought
about in a while and you think okay I
try to forget about her you know cause
it's just like it's shitty it happened
whatever yeah okay it's okay it's okay
yeah all right don't worry about it yeah
I mean it's okay to be sad about
something my mascara is running that's
okay you wiped it off I've had that
happen your mascara run it has yes boy
you probably didn't expect to come in
and get upset just talk about Dixon
[ __ ] in the election you should
understand that when I'm around the odds
are this is going to happen right right
yeah Jimin tend to cry in my presence
draw this out and win I call it making
them squirt so it's one of those things
yeah we want you put out of your mind
right and then it comes back and it's
like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah it's good you got
the person in trouble good yeah [ __ ]
that guy and now guess what [ __ ] did
it did it change you at all or no did it
make you like a different person um it
made me more um like um like more
cautious I guess a little more defensive
to not really
this is not fun it's supposed to be fun
Wednesday no I know I know it's okay
most of the country feels like you do
right now every Wednesday I make sure
the election oh yeah no no it's okay it
happens but you're successful now is the
point yeah you have a good life you
opened your [ __ ] salon it's amazing
yeah it's a dream come true most people
don't get that off the ground I know how
hard you worked for that it's awesome
you were able to come into a terrible
radio show yeah do you want to hear you
want to hear the last clip
yeah with tears okay all right all right
let's hear the last clip did you like
bail uh at the time yeah did you like
that he got high from Monica will in um
Lewinsky I think I made a big deal out
of something a lot of politicians get up
to wait do you think everybody's getting
head no I just think that yeah I'm not
I'm not a big fan of the Clintons and
what they've what they've done since
with the Clinton Foundation and all the
scandals surrounding that don't you feel
they're like the Kennedys the new hip
kennedy the new hip candidate definitely
I just okay as a non-us citizen I find
it incredible the out of a population of
over group of 230 240 million people
nothing like that you've chosen a
candidate who is from the same family as
a previous president same as the bushes
it's a bit more like a dynasty rather
than a democracy to me I get it I get it
are you gonna come tonight we're in your
hands and your sheets this is a radio
interview I was just curious did you
ever get the answer from him no he just
kept giving me weird looks he chose not
to answer it cuz he probably was going
to hey I think it was going all me out
oh you probably did he was like he was
nodding he is a duality yeah I don't
want to talk about it but I'm definitely
gonna come I'm definitely gonna come
well Mary Jean thank you for being a
reporter yeah thank you
I'm sorry that we have set you today oh
it's fine
yeah sometimes it's good you get that
stuff out it's a guy
when you mentally vomit something
sometimes you gotta just yeah yeah I
just forgot sometimes I forget about it
yeah and then when I think about it
again like I think about that time and
I'm like what the [ __ ]
like um could've would have you know
kind of I think like that you blame
yourself you mean like I try to play
myself I just I know better and I'm more
I'm always very cautious I'm very very
alert if a guy is like coming towards me
or something and for me to put myself in
that situation and trust that person and
that person to do that to me it sucks
you know and that's just a lesson in
life and I've learned to just you know I
grow from and that's why I try not to
think about it it's in the past whatever
it happened was something small like one
of those things that was a recent pastor
quite a while ago that you put away like
a year two years ago recent yeah but it
helped like I lost a lot of work for it
too which sucked was work like a lot of
like um people didn't want to work with
me because of what I did
like I report it and oh because so much
that goes unreported yeah yeah and when
you speak on it and and you say
something people try to put you like in
a in a corner you know and they don't
want to touch you they don't talk about
you it's more like oh it's your fault
you should just stay shot or like I got
blamed a lot oh you shouldn't have never
done porn or he wouldn't see you like
that like stuff like that like a private
a lot of ignorant blaming you your
lifestyle choices yeah yeah yeah you
asked for it yeah because like it sucked
well I want you to know the Jim Norton
and I we want to talk to you and touch
you all the time you don't have to worry
about that we feel that way with each
other in Travis - sure we love talking
creeps
we love touches like that's why he stays
behind that glass he certainly does of
course I do
can't get his work done okay now a mess
I'm a flustered man I just reach over
and I grab his little wiener and I pinch
it like cries
uh Hillary is Hillary speaking she's
about to okay maybe we should take a
break
yeah a quick break back let's take a
break we're gonna come back Mary Jean
thank you for coming yes you're having
me it's my first time in the Jim
Martin's - we'll have to do more of
these yes yes I think I am I out of line
when I say Mary Jean I I elect her as
our official on the street correspondent
yeah I can't think of any other options
um my only like semi minor criticism it
was not even it was just make sure that
they're my two so we can hear both of
them that sounds to me like not a
problem with the reporter but a problem
with her engineer perhaps major Ian
Adrienne maybe you could do is you could
Mike
Mary Jean with a wireless only so this
way she's enough to worry about it you
can hold it in their face or you know
what he's gonna do they can be your job
great how do you like that yeah I
understand how it is in the hustle and
the bustle of the Big Apple you get
caught up in the moment I just get
sexual like every time I put Mike in
their mouth I think they're gonna think
about [ __ ] so I try not to you know
put it right in their mouth no it's not
early she's a white Mike you know out of
respect
fighters people scary yeah